as biden takes a victory lap over the
killing of a top al-qaeda leader there
are new concerns that afghanistan could
be a safe haven for terrorists i'm on
all the worry i always say it wrong uh
who was bin laden's deputy and the
mastermind behind 911 he was killed by a
cia drone strike while standing on a
balcony in kabul the cia had tracked his
this top terrorist for months before
taking him out in a wealthy area where
he was staying with his family at the
home of an aide to a taliban leader
zawari's boldness to be out in the open
raises alarms that al qaeda could be
making a comeback in afghanistan the
white house says that's not the case
so we know that the taliban was
harboring
the world's most wanted terrorists
you guys gave a whole country to a bunch
of people that are on the fbi most
wanted list what did you think was going
to happen i take issue with the premise
that we gave a whole country to
terrorist groups i mean again i'd i'd
i'd encourage you to ask him the world's
number one terrorist question i mean
peter the way you ask that it makes it
sound like we owned afghanistan a year
ago it wasn't our country um it was an
independent sovereign state and the
president made a bold decision to end a
war that had been going on for 20 years
but we said at the time
that as we depart afghanistan we're
going to keep vigilant we're going to
stay ready and we're not going to let
afghanistan become a safe haven for
terrorists who threaten our homeland
it always was we don't own it but we
paid a lot of money for it for a long
time so it was kind of like a long-term
lease uh hasn't it always been a haven
for terrorists when did we ever think
that we could trust the taliban no of
course not and we're not going to debate
whether we should have pulled out or not
that debate is over if a republican's
elected president next or another
democrat neither president is going to
put more soldiers back into afghanistan
so the question is now how much
intelligence and informants do we have
in country to be able to pull up for
aerial targeting from drones and it
looks like we have some good assets on
the ground because we just wiped this
guy off the map with this ninja bomb a
hellfire blade missile these things just
slice you up like that it doesn't even
explode slap chop i love it uh i wish i
wish i had known about ninja bombs
before i would have been talking about
that forever
um
yes we're going to see terrorist groups
reconstitute in afghanistan i think we
should assume that but
we just have to keep our eyes on them
with the surveillance up in the sky
that's why we have such expensive
satellites
i'm worried also about the southern
border because if all of a sudden you
can have all these terrorist groups set
up in afghanistan what makes you think
they're not setting up in the northern
triangle in mexico and we just learned
that 56 people on the terror watch list
were nab crossing the southern border
and we have like what like hundreds of
thousands of godaways
every six months so
some terrorists from afghanistan or for
wherever has crossed into our southern
border into our country and the body
administration has not done anything
about it that's what worries me so if
they haven't done anything about it to
this point you know what is the plan
going forward because as much as people
admire admiral kirby and you know he
does a much better job than any other
communications person uh in the federal
government especially right now
do we can we be assured that the united
states has a plan going forward for what
might be brewing in afghanistan
specifically not to mention
other countries and regions they said
their plan was always this over horizon
capability which when they pulled out of
afghanistan was questioned because we
don't have any base nearby so she says
we keep a base in afghanistan to carry
out these attacks so the white house is
using this
moment which is great for the country
great for the world um to say that that
plan is working now they're trying to
spin their way out of the one-year
anniversary of the catastrophic
afghanistan withdrawal which was a
complete disaster one of the largest
hostage crisis we've ever seen there's
still people trapped there who can get
out people who helped us in the war um
and it doesn't excuse that but it is
good to know that they were able to take
him out however i was thinking about the
beau bergdahl swap because when they did
that big rose garden ceremony and it was
like we got our guy back and they sold
it as this really amazing thing
and then people started asking questions
about what actually happened and it
turns out it wasn't what it what they
said it was this is kind of similar um
you know great strike glad he's dead but
the fact that he was in kabul just
hanging out being harbored by the
taliban raises lots of questions about
what's happening there and kirby said
this afternoon that al qaeda is not
reconstituting itself there but this
morning he said that they were actively
planning attacks so
it is a problem but if they can handle
it in the fashion that they did over the
weekend then that's a very good thing
and it keeps soldiers off the ground as
well yes and and that is obviously the
ultimate goal and to your point no
president is going to commit ground
troops to afghanistan um but you know
did the botched withdrawal have an
impact on who felt confident
reconstituting over there you know and
and if we had gotten out differently
would we have a different outcome in
terms of who's there right now
well we do know that terrorists are
paying attention to how we feel about
things here they're monitoring exactly
what our media is saying about what are
people who used to serve in previous
administrations the folks at institutes
like brookings at the council on foreign
relations aei heritage everywhere are
saying about how we're handling our
foreign policy decisions and the
afghanistan withdrawal was universally
decried right and everyone was talking
about how we are
weaker for the way that it was done not
that it wasn't the right decision so i
think they're certainly measuring that
and to add to katie's point about
how he was just hanging out on a balcony
at home in you know in the capitol his
wife and daughter came a few months
earlier and they were just roaming
around like normal people there as well
and we know how valuable obviously
families are of these kinds of
terrorists what i think is interesting
looking forward is you know what's next
for al qaeda so the guy who was the
number three guy bin laden then all
zohari and al-adol al-adal i think is
how you pronounce his name he actually
lives in iran
which creates a whole other complication
to this so people have questioned his
credibility in terms of coming to the
top of the heat because of that or does
this mean that now we're going to be
expanding right and wouldn't iran love
to get in on this kind of conversation
and then are we going to see
uh you know a confluence of these states
that are being run by terrorists turning
against u.s foreign policy well is is
this just was just a political move greg
was just this a way to distract from a
horrible series of news cycles because
you know we're hearing that the cia had
eyeballs on him for months and months
and you know they had developed uh
basically a personality profile of what
he was doing and when he was doing it
they knew where he was they built a
model of the place he was staying in so
you know the strike comes at a curious
time katie brings up
the botched withdrawal was august one
year ago so is this a way to not only
distract from that but also some of
these horrible numbers in terms of gdp
and
inflation i don't know i mean
you know it was like the media was dying
to write those joe's got his groove back
articles they were almost pre-written
like obituaries it kind of sounded like
it in a way and i think it's fair to be
pissed off that this guy was hanging out
casually for who knows how long i mean
what in god's name is a white
supremacist doing in afghanistan
uh but it is a reminder it is a reminder
that terrorism never goes away it just
grows a tale or it grows ahead and when
bad stuff happens under a president it's
on them and when good stuff happens
under them
yeah there you go no i think you got i
think you got to give him credit but the
problem with joe
and the pro the heart what's hard about
giving him credit is that he refuses
responsibility for the bad stuff so it's
kind of hard when something good happens
to padam on the back even though i think
we should even though we know that he
probably had very little to do with this
he's kept in the dark like a rare
mushroom he was totally against uh bin
laden killing bin laden so i don't know
i i think he was just he's very lucky
and solimani as well yes but i do think
it's a cost for celebration when
somebody like this dies i think it's i'm
very reluctant to turn good news into
bad uh given the choices you know i'd
rather have al zahari dead than alive i
wish we'd killed him
20 or 30 years ago 20 years ago when he
was in his 50s you know he outlived
ashley babbitt by 35 years i would
rather have that reversed all right well
said thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else